words x equals y in which case we're simply imagining that fi is changing the state of the system and indeed this is
very often the situation that we're interested in but this possibility is consistent with the first bullet point in the sense that we never have the
input and output systems existing as two separate systems at the same time and in any case it's going to be convenient for
the purposes of this lesson to use different letters namely X and Y to refer to the input and output systems
just to help us to keep things straight now let's go into a little bit more detail about the requirement that channels always transform density
matrices into density matrices let's suppose that we introduce a new system Z into the picture let's
give the name gamma to the classical State set of this new system imagine now that we form a new compound system ZX
consisting of the new system together with the input system X of a channel fi and suppose that this compound system is
in a state described by a density Matrix row this can be an arbitrary Quantum state of this pair but whatever state it
is it's always possible to express the density Matrix Row in the form that's shown on the screen where both A and B
range over the classical State set gamma and each row AB is some Matrix whose rows and columns correspond to whatever
the classical State set of X is and we don't need to give that classical State set a name at this point just to be clear each row AB is not necessarily a
density Matrix on its own but the entire Matrix row is necessarily a density Matrix when we apply the channel 5 to
the system X it gets transformed into Y and so we're left with the pair zy and the way that we determine the
state of this pair after performing fi on just X is to evaluate the linear mapping fi on each of the matrices row a
another way to say this is that we take the tensor product of the mapping fi with the identity mapping on Square matrices having rows and columns
corresponding to gamma and that in turn corresponds to doing nothing to this new system Z but this is an equivalent
description and it doesn't necessitate going into any details about tensor products of mappings of this form they
do however work in a pretty straightforward way that's analogous to how they work for vectors and matrices one way to think about this visually is
in terms of block matrices and if we make the simplifying assumption that the classical stat set gamma consists of the
integers between 0 and N minus one for some positive integer M then it becomes easy to write all of this down as is
shown right here and now to reiterate the requirement that we're placing on five in order for it to be a valid Channel we must always obtain a density
Matrix from this process and this has to be true regardless of what choice we make for the system Z as well as the
choice we make for row provided that it's a density Matrix that might seem like a pretty strict requirement and it
might also seem like it's very difficult to check but as we'll see by the end of the lesson it's actually not so strict
or difficult to check and in particular we have nice mathematical characterizations for this condition
which are connected with the different representations that we'll talk about a bit later in the lesson now let's take a look at some examples of channels
starting with an entire category of channels called unitary channels in simple terms these are unitary
operations just like we have in the simplified formulation of quantum information viewed as channels to be precise suppose that U is a unitary
Matrix that represents a unitary operation on a system X so in the simplified formulation of quantum
information we would multiply this Matrix to a given Quantum State Vector to determine the action that that operation has on that Quantum State the
way that this works for density matrices is that we multiply the density Matrix on the left by U and on the right by U
dagger in mathematical terms we refer to this operation as conjugation by The Matrix U this is consistent with KSI
brasai being the density Matrix that describes the state represented by the quantum State Vector s and it's pretty
easy to check that in particular if we were to perform U on the quantum State Vector Ki then we'd get U * Ki and its
density Matrix representation is given by that Vector times its conjugate transpose which is U * Ki * brasai * U
dagger when we evaluate the conjugate transpose of U * Ki so the way that this channel is defined
makes sense for Pure States and when we combine this with linearity we see that it makes sense for density matrices in
general owing to the fact that every density Matrix can be expressed as a convex combination of pure States this
definition always gives us a valid channel for any choice of a unitary operation u in particular conjugating by
a unitary Matrix like this doesn't change the trace of a matrix and if we conjugate any positive semi-definite
matrix by any Matrix at all we'll get another positive semi-definite Matrix and it's pretty easy to get that
directly from the definition of positive semi-definite matrices so density matrices always get mapped to density
matrices and all of this remains true even if we tensor you with the identity Matrix of any size which is equivalent
to applying this channel to just part of a compound system here's a really simple example of a unitary Channel suppose we
take U itself to be the identity Matrix this is very obviously a valid Channel called the identity Channel doing
nothing at all is certainly a linear operation and if we start with a density Matrix and we do nothing to it it's
still going to be a density Matrix so this is a valid Channel people use different symbols to denote this channel
sometimes it's exactly the same symbol we use for the identity Matrix which can be a little bit confusing but it generally isn't here I'm using the
letters ID short for identity just to avoid any confusion and this notation is also pretty common it might seem like a
very boring Channel but in the context of information transmission it's actually a perfect Channel where the
receiver gets exactly what the sender sends which is typically what one wants most in that context another way we can
obtain lots of examples of channels is to take convex combinations of channels or in other words to average them
together and the fact that we can do this is an important aspect of channels to explain this in more detail let's start with two channels F0 and 51 let's
say along with a real number P between 0 and one and just to be clear we're assuming that these two channels have
the same input system which is X as well as the same output system which is y and now consider what happens if we decide
to apply the first channel F0 with probability p and otherwise with the remaining probability 1 minus P we apply
the second Channel F1 for instance maybe we randomly choose a bit with those probabilities and then use this random
bit to determine which channel to apply by doing this we're effectively applying a new Channel which we might call sigh
that's given by a convex combination of the two channels that we started with and which we can express as is written
on the screen we can always take linear combinations of linear Maps like this by the way and the way that a linear